KNOW MORE ABOUT WILL IN UKRAINE
THEN HUNTER BIDEN.
WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF TIME
LEFT.
BREAKING JUST BEFORE THE SHOW
CAME ON TONIGHT, A HUGE
DEVELOPMENT.
THE PRESIDENT REFERRED TO IT
SURROUNDING A NONWHISTLE-BLOWER
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
HIS COMPLAINT AS WE HAVE BEEN
SAYING BUT THE POLITICAL HITCH
ALL ALONG.
NOW, IF HE WANTS ANYONE TO TAKE
HIM SERIOUSLY, HE BETTER GET A
DIFFERENT LAWYER.
FOXNews.com BREAKING TONIGHT.
THEY HAVE UNCOVERED A SERIES OF
TWEETS FROM THE FAKE
WHISTLE-BLOWER'S ATTORNEY.
THIS THIS GUY'S NAME IS MARK
THEY MAKE NO MISTAKE DOWNRIGHT
DISTURBING AND TERMS OF IT IS
NOW OBVIOUS THAT THIS LAWYER IS
DESPICABLE, DERANGED, THE
TRUMPETER, PARTISAN HACK
PLOTTING THE PRESIDENT'S
DESTRUCTION STARTING TEN DAYS
AFTER INAUGURATED.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN, JANUARY 30,
2017.
THEY READ TWEETING NEWS ABOUT
ACTING AG SALLY GATES GETTING
FIRED.
LOOK AT THIS, CAPTIONED HASHTAG
WHO HAS STARTED, FIRST OF MANY
STEPS, HASHTAG IMPEACHMENT WILL
FOLLOW ULTIMATELY, HASHTAG
LAWYERS.
IF YOU MUNCH LATER AS JULY 1ST,
2017 TWEETING WE WILL GET HIM
AND THIS COUNTRY STRONG ENOUGH
TO SURVIVE EVEN HIM AND HIS
SUPPORTERS.
WE HAVE TO.
TWEETING INCESSANTLY ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S IMPEACHMENT.
COMPARISON TO NIXON TWEETS
FANTASIZING OPENLY WHAT IT WILL
BE LIKE FOR THE PRESIDENT TO BE
IMPEACHED AND OF COURSE, THERE
IS EVEN A TWEET HIGHLIGHTING HOW
FAKE NEWS CNN WILL HELP TAKE
TRUMP DOWN.
I PREDICT CNN WILL PLAY A KEY
ROLE IN PRESIDENT STOMACH
TRUMPED UP FINISHING OUT FULL
TERM AS PRESIDENT.
WHO HAS STARTED.
WE WILL GET RID OF THEM AND CNN
WILL PLAY A KEY ROLE.
THIS IS THE EMBODIMENT OF RAGE,
HATRED AND I'M WILLING TO ACCEPT
THE ELECTION RESULTS.
TRUMP DERANGEMENT SYNDROME.
THIS IS A SO-CALLED
WHISTLE-BLOWER,
NONWHISTLE-BLOWER, THAT IS HIS
LAWYER?
HONESTLY WE ARE TO BELIEVE THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER HAD THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE COUNTRY AT MIND?
KNOW, BY THE WAY IT IS TIME TO
PUT HIM UNDER OATH.
PUT THE COMPROMISE COWARD,
CORRUPT SCHIFF HIMSELF UNDER
OATH.
BIDEN NEEDS TO GO UNDER OATH.